i love your souls
[Music]
i love
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've met a few
[Music]
till
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we the champions
of the world
[Music]
i thank you all but it's
been no bed of roses
[Music]
no pleasure crew
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my friends
[Applause]
[Music]
we are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j
[Music]
trump
who
[Applause]
[Music]
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's kind we stand and say
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend still today
[Music]
wow thank you what a crowd what a
beautiful crowd look at that you can't
even see the end of it
what a great crowd thank you very much
hello wisconsin we're back
we're back we're going to win we're
going to win this state
we win this date you know what it's over
we win wisconsin i've treated wisconsin
very well four days from now we're going
to win this state and we are going to
win
four more beautiful years in the world
with your support we will continue to
bring back your jobs cut your taxes cut
regulations
support our great police defend our
borders without borders we don't have a
country do we
protect our second amendment protect
religious liberty and ensure
more products are proudly stamped with
those
beautiful words made in the usa
we're starting to do that you remember i
used to say
four years ago we're going to bring back
the words
merry christmas we did right merry
christmas
those big department stores are like
happy new year i said no you can say
them both but you can't do one without
the other
merry christmas is back you notice that
right
and pretty soon we're going to be there
joe biden will shut down your state's
economy
wipe out your factories ship your jobs
to china
to china that's paid them off by the way
china that's paid them off you know that
right
although you don't get too much news but
yet enough you know what's going on
they don't like giving you the news
punish your family with a 4
trillion tax hike eliminate private
health care 180 million people have
private health care they want to take it
away
and send your state into a
catastrophic you want to use the word
recession of depression
because the word is depression biden has
vowed to eliminate the entire u.s oil
industry no fracking
no energy and gas prices going five
six seven dollars for a gallon how do
you like two dollar
gasoline good
[Applause]
there'll be no heating in the winter no
air conditioning of the summer and no
electricity whatever the hell you wanted
right now you haven't made you're so
lucky
you are so lucky i'm your president
[Applause]
and your team is doing a good job right
they're doing a good job
right they're doing a good job and while
i'm president america will proudly
remain
energy independent how does that sound
first time
you're energy independent we're the
biggest in the world nobody close
biden will deliver poverty misery
depression
i will deliver jobs jobs jobs and the
greatest economy
in the history of our country that's
going to be next year you see it
it was announced last quarter our
economy grew
at the astonishing speed 33.1
the largest gdp growth ever recorded
and not just by a little bit by more
than double
[Applause]
and that was in 1952 but more than
double think of it
it's never been anything like that for
any country not only ours
for any country in the past five months
we've created a record
11.4 million american jobs we have a
super v i used to talk about the v
this is no longer a v this is a super v
this is despite the fact
that the democrat governors have states
shut down right gee does that sound
hey does that sound familiar to you
middle class family income is up more
than 6 000
under my administration far greater than
the
past administration i mean that was not
up
that was doing very poorly we created
the greatest economy in history
and now we're doing it again make
america great again
again we did it once
at hat see that hat is now absolutely
let's go
make america great again again in a very
recent poll
gallup they said 56 of americans said
they were doing better today than they
were
four years ago and we're rounding the
turn on a pandemic and it's 56
and it's the highest number they've ever
recorded so we're doing something right
joe biden spent the last 47 years
outsourcing your jobs
opening your borders and sacrificing
american blood
and treasure in endless foreign wars in
countries that most of you have never
even heard of
i mean think of it and you know at the
debate did anybody see the debate by any
chance
so during the debate he'd say well we're
going to do this i said joe why didn't
you do it
we're going to do that we're going to do
this and that this and that
joe why didn't you do it joe that wasn't
easy to pay
91 to 9 they said that was good
that's like that's like a great football
game no i said but joe
i said joe why didn't you do it uh well
i don't know
exactly and then the last question was a
disaster basically he said
no more oil no more fracking no more
anything
i said did he say that and i just said
we just left a great place you know that
it was a little cold there you know this
is like warm by comparison
this is a pleasure ah this is a pleasure
that was cold i said let's cut this a
little bit shorter
but we have a big crowd you know we had
a big crowd no matter where we go we
have these massive crowds
and i'm going up i'm going up to
minnesota we're going to minnesota
which we have a chance not since 1972
think of it so
so those are odds that aren't good but
they like us
up there with the iron range all the
things i've done for them up there and
helping them when the rioters and
anarchists attacked
we took over and we did a great job but
they should have called us two weeks
earlier in all fairness
if they called us federal government if
they called us two weeks earlier that
would have been nice you know you would
have had no problem
it took us about what 25 minutes to
solve the problem right
mom they just marched down but we're
going and the governor
just informed us though that so we have
25 000 people 25
000 people that's a lot you got a lot
here
25 000 people in minnesota they said we
can only have 250 people
so they were hoping i'd say oh well we
can't do that let's turn around no we're
going to go
we're going to go you're very interested
even if we see 250 people jenna be
honest with you
everybody understands you can't play
those games
that could very well aside from aside
from
omar omar is our secret welcome
ilhan omar that's our secret weapon in
minnesota
now she doesn't love our country you
know i don't like people that don't love
our country i don't
[Music]
and the other and you know all about
this because you've had your things the
others we want law and order we've got
to have law and order
you look at what's going on in
philadelphia you can't have that
you have to let the police do what they
do i mean they have to do their job
when i watch that again democrats it's
all democrats when i watch that of
people are
looting stores and you have the
anarchists the rioters but they're
looting stores they're walking out with
dishwashers they're walking down guys
has a dishwasher he couldn't even
pushing it they're washing
i mean they have television sets and
they're walking and the police are
standing there
and those police don't want to be
standing there they don't want to do
that
they want to be able to do their job but
they're not and you can't have that we
need
law and order as we had
as we had right here as we did a very
good job right here we got the
endorsement of everybody everybody in
your state every law enforcement group
in your state endorsed us every law
i think every law enforcement group in
the country endorses i asked uh sleepy
joe during one of the debates i said joe
joe who endorsed you from law
enforcement and he couldn't answer the
question
now that's possibly that happened but
he's got a very bad memory too he can
he was going let me think give me about
20 minutes i'll figure it out
i doubt he has any i doubt he has any i
think we have everybody
we have everybody florida texas oklahoma
chicago endorses isn't that nice chicago
with all the problems with all the
problems they have but those they have a
great
they have a great group of people from
law enforcement they could stop those
problems i mean you'd see what's going
on there new york has gone through the
roof new york's finest
we have new york's finest these are
incredible police they could do the job
but they have to be allowed to do the
job
and they endorsed me first time in the
history
of the police force in new york that
they endorsed a presidential candidate
so it was pretty cool
[Applause]
so joe biden tried to cut medicare
during the course of his terms and he
worked very hard in cutting social
security
you wouldn't believe that right and we
actually put it up we put it on where is
that screen
for places that we really like we use
the screen it's very expensive
you'll see biden was a cheerleader for
nafta which is the worst trade deal ever
made
and china's entry into the world trade
organization which cost wisconsin
130 minimum manufacturing jobs
at every turn biden betrayed american
workers and twisted his
knife into the back of wisconsin workers
you
you suffered as much as anybody biden's
also spent half a century
really a half a century betraying
black americans he devastated black
families with the
1994 crime bill and he called
black youth super predators a term
that's a terrible term super predators
over and over again and then he wonders
why they're not doing well with the
black vote you know the black votes not
turning out for him see now we don't
have to go by the fake polls
now you see what's happening he's not
doing well with the black vote you know
why
because they remember that and they
remember in 1994 and they remember him
calling everybody a super predator
and that's a term that they don't like
that's a term that nobody would like
but they're not showing up to vote and
others aren't either
you know we're doing great in florida
we're doing great in ohio we're doing
great in
north carolina was fantastic i think
we're doing really good in pennsylvania
we're doing very good in pennsylvania i
think we're doing good all
over the place you want another
i think we're doing good all alone
we're doing great here you know i think
they just said to here we're either tied
or one up or tied or when done you know
it's it's
like essentially i don't know how the
hell i can be tied with this guy
he's shot he's shot he said sir you're
tired in wisconsin you know normally
that means because we have like a hidden
voter
people that don't want to talk about it
they just go out and vote for trump
i never knew should i be complimented by
that
we don't want to talk about it leave us
alone we're voting for trump right
so when you died that's a good thing but
they said sir we're tied
and i said that's interesting and then
the fake washington post
abc right did you see that so we are
todd i was up here two days ago we gave
a great speech that was a cold one
we gave a speech on a racetrack we got a
lot of people to do with freezing but i
got through that i was
there was no way that i leave early
on the great people of wisconsin because
you don't you don't know about that
there is no way anyway this ball so
we're tied let's say we're tied
one up one down we're right boom very
close i think we're going to take it
easily actually i think we're going to
take it
because we're going to have a turnout
probably on tuesday you know our people
like to vote
they like to vote on tuesday not even on
sunday or monday
that's what so washington post and abc
it's called washington post abc paul
they come out 17 down donald trump is 17
down in wisconsin
i said i said wait a minute i just left
the crowd of
25 000 people or more they were going
crazy
that wasn't a second place crowd you
know we know a second place clear
that was not a second place crowd and
they did it to me four years ago
with crooked hillary they had me they
had me
he's down 12 two weeks ago remember
washington post abc crooked as hell
it's called suppression pulse you know
what it does it suppresses the vote you
get depressed you like trump you know i
like the president but
let's uh and then the case four years
ago i like donald trump he's going to do
a good job
we did more than we said we were going
to do we did more than any
administration
has ever done in the first three and a
half years but it's a suppression thing
so they came out 12 down we actually
wrote them legal letters and everything
and then they changed the vote can you
believe it they change it
one down but that was the day before the
election two weeks to go
12 down but this one was 17 down in your
state
and i said you know i could be three
down i could also be three up
i could be three down i could be four
down i could also be three up a four
up one thing i know i'm not 17 dad so
so i called up the best poster guy
doesn't matter let's just call him john
his first name's john
i said john can i ask you a question i
just left wisconsin
we had a tremendous crowd it was like a
love fest
and then i i wake up through and then i
wake up uh
like two days later and i see a poll
washington post it's all over the place
you know they love it all the fake news
look at all of them back
they're fake
among the most dishonest people in the
world now they have a new thing they
don't report
they don't report on you know
criminality like with the biden crime
family you know they don't want to
report but fortunately we have guys like
ron
johnson that are willing to
say it like it is
it's actually very true what i just said
he's fantastic but we'll get to him
later
your senator is fantastic so
you take a look and i said i'm not 17
now and he's a
really smart crisis no you're not i said
but don't they have to pay a price like
you know they did it 12 down
four years ago and now said isn't it a
bad thing he said yeah but they want you
to lose
i said well why don't they make it that
i'm three down or two down or you know
make it like believable no no
three down or two down's no good because
if they go
three down two down four even five i
said make it five he said no no good
because that means you have a chance
that might even bring people out
they want to make it so bad and they
said no they're very smart people
they're very vicious people
and they purposely make these polls
phony they're phony polls
and he said the only way they really can
do it they have to make it
so that the people here think you're 17
down and they don't go and vote because
they say it's hopeless
five down four down three down means g
he has a chance 17 down means
darling let's go to dinner let's have a
wonderful dinner and then watch come
we'll come home and watch the president
lose but we're not gonna lose we're
gonna win
isn't that some story that's sad and he
knows the people he said no this is the
way they do it they're very
and then they came with another
statewide 10 down that are going to
actually win this state
it's a it's a terrible thing we have
tremendous dishonesty
in polling but not only paul i mean the
stories
and now there's something that happened
we call them freedom of the press right
this is the opposite of freedom of the
press because they now suppress
it's now suppression of the press
because now they have stories
and they don't want to have you cannot
get a story out
on biden criminality
we have the laptop from hell we have the
worst things anyone's ever seen
and they just won't write about it and
that includes big tech
so you know what i'm doing i'm i'm
here's who i'm facing
a corrupt democrat party that spied on
my campaign and we caught him
they spy to the campaign
exactly see i never do anything to just
you know to
to like encourage it because they say he
led the chant
lock him up lock him up he led the chain
against crooked hillary all she did was
get rid of 33
000 emails when she got a subpoena from
congress
she deleted them she acid washed them
and then she took a hammer to her
telephones and she beat the hell out of
the phone
i've gotten rid of a lot of phones i've
never hit him with a hammer has anybody
hit the phone with a hammer i don't know
well we'll have to tell that to ron
johnson we can put that that is a
strange
event ron i bet i bet you never hit your
phone with a hat no it's called you
throw it out right
you throw out your phone you start all
over again
now we got a corrupt bunch of people but
think of it i'm all up here alone
think of this i have the democrats
they impeach me for making a phone call
no i make a phone call to a man i never
met the president the new president of
ukraine
congratulations congratulations it was a
perfect phone call
everybody said it 297 to nothing in the
house the republicans voted right
it's like this perfect phone call
congratulate everyone's telling me
please call him he just won oh
do i have you know i'm busy right i say
okay i'll call him
get the president nice guy
congratulations
by the way if you see any crime because
we're supposed to have a crime because
it's a lot of corruption there
please report it to the attorney general
of the united states oh we should
impeach him
i got impeached over a perfect phone
call
but they didn't know we had the call
essentially recorded thank goodness we
had because they were making up stories
right
they died when they heard we had it
transcribed
by very professional people they died
because it had already been way down the
track by the time they found that out i
had to do that we called up we said do
you mind if we put your phone call
on public record they said why would
that be it was just a congratulatory
call
i said well you'll find out these are
bad people so here's what we have
we have the democrats now we have big
tech
now we also have the rhinos now the
rhinos in many ways are worse than all
of them
and and most of the rhinos i beat
because you know they were all
representing one of the 17 because we
had 18 running
but they were who most of whom i get
along with some of them i don't like i
could tell you the good ones are the bad
ones
but i beat all of these guys and they
end up being rhinos and bad people
and here we are and we're president
we're gonna have i think we're gonna
have something that's even better than
what we did four years ago i really
believe that
i really believe
because you don't have crowds like this
and be on the losing stick you know you
leave here he said gee that doesn't
sound like a second place you can't even
see the end of the crowd
that doesn't look like a second place
finish here
so when you hear about suppression you
have some very nice people up there
about two of them but when you hear
about
when you hear about when you hear this
right
i know every one of them some of them
are great actually
uh but we're gonna have a big victory
and this election is the most important
election
of our lifetime this is a more important
election
than the last one and i never thought
i'd say it because they have gone so far
radical left that we have to make this
final step and we're going to have
we're going to be normalizing our
country really normalizing our country
and you know what else normalizes its
success i'll tell you before the
the plague came in from china they
should have never let it happen
but before the plague came in from china
i was getting calls from people that you
would least expect
it was time we had the best numbers the
best employment the best
everything the stock market all-time
high everything was the best
and they were like let's talk and it was
happening and then we got hit with the
plague
success brings this country together and
we're going to have
we're going to have success next year
we're going to have success next you
know the most successful year wisconsin
ever had was last year you're going to
have a year i mean unless some guy gets
in that wants to quadruple your taxes
which he wants to do
he's the only guy i've ever seen we will
raise your taxes all my life i've seen
politicians say we're going to cut your
taxes
he's the only guy ever campaigning on
he's going to increase your taxes
in 2016 wisconsin voted to fire
this corrupt political establishment and
you elected
an outsider as president who is finally
putting america first
if i don't sound like a typical
politician it's because i'm not a
politician if that's okay
and if i don't always play by the rules
of washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you
and i fight harder for you than any
president
at any time in the history of our
[Applause]
culture
that's so nice thank you that's a chance
that has never been heard politically
nobody's ever even these people they
have there's never been a time we like
ronald reagan we like people but they've
never had that chance so it's an honor i
don't keep it going too long because
i'll start to cry
and we can't tell president xi of china
that the president was crying because
they said
they loved him right and the fake news
would report it
president trump broke down in tears as
they
shouted somehow it doesn't work for us
right we can't do that right look at him
he goes no way you can't do it
now we appreciate it it is it's a chant
that nobody's ever heard before
it started happening like six weeks ago
and i said man that's very unusual
but it's a beautiful chant and i
appreciate it i'm not just running
against sleepy joe biden
i'm running against the left-wing media
the big tech giants and
the washington swamp and it's deep and
vicious
and they can't believe what's happening
they can't believe it they would have
taken most people out
almost anybody would have been taken out
and i have been helped a lot
by that man right there named ron
johnson
[Applause]
he's a tough guy and he's a smart guy
and i knew it
earlier than anybody else i knew it i
had a meeting with ron johnson and we
were going over very complex sex
most people had no idea what we were
even talking about he understood it
so good i mean so he really understood
it so i knew a long time ago what you
had don't lose him don't ever lose him
you need to show up in record numbers
and deliver a blistering defeat
to these corrupt forces and they are
corrupt as hell
they're trying to take over our country
and we caught them they're coming for
your guns
they're coming for your jobs and they're
coming for your freedom
think about it your vote will stop them
on november 3rd get out there you got to
vote it's the most important
issue one of the most truly important
issues it's you don't like to even
mention it but it's law and order
and i mentioned that to biden during one
of the debates i said hey joe
say the words law and order can you do
it he wouldn't do it
because he didn't want to lose the
radical left he didn't want to lose them
joe biden and his party have spent the
entire year inciting violence and hatred
against our police officers
and he refuses to say you got to stop it
you cannot run through portland to
destroy the city i mean it's been going
on
we could stop it in 30 minutes you know
in seattle
i said i don't care we waited and waited
the governor never called we waited
i said you got to go and they took over
a part of the city i mean this is even
to even talk about this who would think
of the seattle
and we were going in and we told them
we're coming in in the morning and you
know what they did that evening they
raised their hand and they left that was
the end of it
and a lot of people are paying a big
price by the way but they raised their
hands and they left
or the statues we signed a law
you knocked down statues they were
knocking down statues all over the
country
you knock down statues you go to jail
for 10 years
it's an old law
it's amazing how we haven't seen too
much trouble
with statues there were groups that
formed they wanted to do it they were
they wanted and then they said let's get
the hell out of here 10 years
10 years it says 10 years in prison old
law that we reenacted
you could never get that passed today
with this crazy group nancy pelosi and
crying chuck schumer
crying chuck schumer and nancy would
never pass anything like that
did say uh no you're allowed to rip down
anything you want
you know we have a dc mayor that set up
a commission right
to talk about all of the things cancer
culture let's talk
about they don't like the washington
monument
they want it renamed or taken down this
was their recommendation don't worry
about it we're not doing
i promise you they don't like the thomas
jefferson memorial
because they don't like it they don't
even know why tell me why
and they don't like even the lincoln
memorial right
they don't like the lincoln so they
wanted recommendations to change the
name or take them down
and i said i think this commission
should be immediately disbanded
because it's not going anywhere but they
are i mean these are
this is a fact take down the washington
monument
these people are stone cold crazy you
have to go out and you have to vote
biden stands with the rioters and
loaders and biden wouldn't say anything
about the report they asked him about
the report he didn't want to come i have
no comment
do you want to take down the washington
monument sir i have no comment on that
uh yeah he has no clue he never had much
of a clue
now we know he i stand with the heroes
of law enforcement these are great
people that we have to
help them
if biden wins the rioters and the
streets
they'll be running your federal
government they'll be running your
government
no city no family and no community will
be safe
the biden harris how about harris kamala
kamala and you have to say her name
writer she gets very upset
right even though she doesn't say it
right you know
but the biden harris plan would end cash
bail releasing 400
000 dangerous criminals immediately onto
your streets
murderers and rapists this is what's
going on
is crazy when the violent mob
came to a place known as kenosha did you
ever hear of kenosha
because i did remember what i did if i
didn't get if i didn't activate
immediately
kenosha would not be there any longer
they were going to take it down
biden opposed sending in the national
guard and i insisted on it
and i frankly wish the governor asked me
sooner
but at least he asked me but we came in
and that was over in about another 15
minutes right that didn't take long
that didn't take long and we saved
kenosha so you still have kenosha
they knocked down they burned a couple
of buildings down i went i met with the
people and
really good people one was there a
hundred years a photography store it was
a hundred years they burned down the
store but
it's going to get rebuilt but we stopped
it that whole
area would have been burned to the
ground so we uh we came in and
it was so easy too it's easy but you
sometimes have to meet force with force
you can't just stand back sit back and
watch it take place
like they did in minneapolis and then we
went in and it took place very quickly
like usually if it takes like more than
a half an hour
to wipe the whole thing out i say you're
not doing a very good job
biden's running mate the most liberal
senator in america
even urged their supporters to donate to
a fund that bailed out the rioters took
him right out of jail
including a cop killer or an attempted
cop killer
biden wants to lock down your homes he's
ready to lock it down
i mean you guys are already in a
lockdown so you you might not notice it
as much
hey governor you got to open up your
state here you got to open it up
[Music]
got to open it up
[Music]
you know it's uh it's sad it said you
got to go back you understand you're
going to
socially distance you're going to do all
the things you want to do but
i mean we're having these outdoor
rallies it's they say outdoor outdoor
normally would go into an arena i
actually like this stuff better
although sometimes it's snowing and
sleet
i love that last stop but it was the
rain was formed like
sideways it was going
that stuff that's when you say i love
the indoor arenas but i like these
with a day like this it's so beautiful
it's great is there
any place better to be than a trump
rally though seriously
it's great but this election is a choice
between
a trump super boom or a biden depression
that's what it is
and it's also between opening up
and keeping it closed you see what's
happening in europe they're trying it
again they're going to close up
they closed up and they destroyed their
economy our economy is so much better so
much stronger
went down so much less and now it's come
up faster than any country in the world
but ours is between a safe vaccine which
is coming very shortly it's a
momentarily
or devastating lockdown that's what
biden wants to do because he has no
choice
uh he doesn't he will not call the shots
he will not call the shots
and everybody knows it thanks to our
historic campaign to slash
red tape and mobilize industry we will
deliver a safe vaccine to the american
people
in literally over the next few weeks we
think over the next few weeks
there was a lot of pressure there was a
lot of pressure on everybody including
on the fda
not to let this happen before the
election so let me tell you
if biden was in charge of this vaccine
just like the swine flu he was in charge
of
h1n1 right which he can never get right
he can't remember it
it's always messed up sometimes he does
n1 h1 i say no
but it's the swine flu i said just go
with the swine flu it's easier right
it's the same thing
call it the swine flu it was a
catastrophe
and his own chief of staff said it was
the dumbest run thing they've ever done
and the lethality is much less than what
this was and
is it was and sort of was because we
have therapeutics now that are
incredible in fact
here i am i'm here
they gave me a shot the regeneron it's
called and others eli lilly now have the
antibodies out
and i'd like to say it had no impact but
i wasn't feeling good like to say
because of my
physical power my strength my young age
i made the case i made the case cnn got
very angry i said i'm not concerned
no i i said when i got better i got
better quick
[Applause]
now cnn got very angry fake news cnn is
totally fake
i said no i beat it because i'm in
perfect physical shape and i'm a very
young person
[Music]
well our first lady got it got better
baron got it he got better so fast we
didn't even know
we said the doctor said sir baron has
tested positive i said for what
and he's very young and very tall he's
seriously tall and he's a good kid but
he's a strong kid but he's a kid and
the immune systems so they said uh dr
sean he's great he's a white house
physician and
he said baron tested positive i said for
what he said
for covid you know there's like 30
different names i happen to
call it the china plague or the
chinavarts because it's
more it's it's more accurate right
and like you know about 14 minutes later
i said how's baron doing oh he's
recovered fully
i said baron were you feeling bad i
didn't know anything dad
i did what was wrong dude no they
you know they have a very strong by the
way speaking of that get back to school
get back to school okay back to school
right look at ron saying agrees
seniors will be the first in line to get
it and
we will uh we're making it available
free because it's not your fault that
this thing happened
and the vaccine by the way with or
without the vaccine we're rounding the
term but the vaccine makes it go faster
the vaccines are going to be out very
soon
very very soon our vaccine will
eradicate the virus and the pandemic
quickly restore
normal life i just want normal life
all we want is normal life
i'm looking up to this guy a friend of
mine said you know you're the most
famous man in the world i said
no i'm not no i'm not no he said no
who's more famous than you you are the
most
famous man in the world what are you
talking about who's more famous i said
jesus christ
[Applause]
and i don't want to take any chances so
i looked up and i said
and it's not even close
all right but next year will be the
greatest economic year in the history of
our country joe biden's plan will delay
the vaccine
postpone therapies crash the economy and
lock down
the entire country he doesn't mind
locking down the country the country
could not stand it
you know we locked it down shortly we
did it we figured it out
we protect our elderly people etc but he
thinks it's
fine he loves that whole deal i'll tell
you all he talks about is covered
he gets up today he's talking kovit
kovetkova komikova kovakova
and the truth is we have done an
incredible job with our ventilators the
vaccines our therapeutics
but all he does because he's got nothing
else he can talk about
because no administration in the history
of our country
has done what we've done i say it all
the times in the first three and a half
years what we've done with
uh tax cuts and regulation cuts and
rebuilding our military which was
totally depleted and a disaster what
we've done with our military and so many
other things you know them all
nobody's done and they never even
question me you know the fake news with
all the cameras
it's never like where they come oh you
shouldn't have said that nobody's done
until you think of it space force
we could name right we could name so
many different things under the biden
lockdown
countless americans will die from
suicide
drug overdoses deferred medical care
and you'll have no school no graduations
no weddings no thanksgiving no christmas
no fourth of july
no future other than that he's doing a
fantastic job
biden wants to keep everyone locked up
even young americans who are extremely
low risk like we talked about he wants
to steal
the dreams and the future of our young
people you know
one thing we've learned the you know the
computers are great and the laptops
everything's great and for telehealth
it's been great
what people can say and it's really been
i think it's up like 7
000 or something and it's a great thing
but you know for school learning
it's terrible it doesn't work it can't
compare to a class or a campus
they're trying so hard to say oh gee
this is wonderful
it doesn't compare and it's well
documented
you're taking you're taking a large
percentage
of a young life at a play
and it's a terrible thing you're doing
to to
young kids and you it's a terrible thing
that's happening with the parents too
because the kids at school and the
parents are working now the parents
don't know what to do
many of their jobs are gone anyway now
you got to open up your state you got to
do it fast
you got to do it fast
[Applause]
thanks to our relentless efforts only
three percent
of the emergency room visits nationwide
are related to the virus think of that
three percent
because you know what it is they only
talk about cases the reason we have so
many cases because we test
if i tested half you know they said test
test test
we test more than any country in the
world by far we have the best tests
these are things that we never even had
six months ago now if i
said let's cut the testing down in half
you'd have half
everyone say oh the but you know what
it's good because we know if there's a
problem etc etc we know if there's a hot
spot
but that's exactly what it is i mean but
what we do and what we've done
so well are the therapies and if you
think of it the fatality rate
is down 85 percent and more now think of
that
[Applause]
[Music]
but they talk about cases because you
know when you hear three percent of the
emergency rooms are devoted you know
it's supposed to be a hundred percent
and the hospitals are gonna
close they don't know what's going on
it's it's been amazing what we've
been able to do but you don't hear them
talking about death you hear them
talking about because as a percentage
what we've done compared to other
countries is incredible
and now especially with the explosion
that you see taking place over in europe
so we've done a great job and i'll tell
you what our vice president's been
fantastic and
you compare you compare vice presidents
and if you don't mind i'll take the one
we have okay
you talk about a victory at a debate
that was one of the greatest victories
at a debate i've ever seen
that one wasn't even close our excess
mortality rate is
42 lower than europe think of that where
cases are now
surging despite very powerful lockdowns
that they've been
they've had very powerful lockdowns but
don't take my word for it
i want to just show you something on a
screen okay
very special people get this we have a
video on our fight against
the china virus and a couple of other
quick things
again we only do this for extremely
important states
and people go ahead
the fact is every time i've uh called
the president he's quickly gotten on the
line
when we asked to get support for that
mercy ship in southern california
he was able to direct that in real time
what the federal government
did working with states was a phenomenal
accomplishment
we got 2 000 of these vehicle field
medical sites that are up almost all
operational now in the state
uh because of his support and those are
the facts uh his
team has been on it i know a team when
they're on it
and i know a team when they're not on it
his team is on it they've been
responsive
late at night early in the morning we
are working very well with fema region 2
and with the army corps of engineers
building four field hospitals that was a
decision the president himself took and
i'm grateful for it
these were just extraordinary efforts
and acts of mobilization
and uh the federal government stepped up
uh we needed help and they were there he
said everything
that i could have hoped for uh and we
had a very long conversation
uh and every single thing he said they
followed through on
we've gotta have double the number of
ventilators that we requested for that
area of the state and in fact
uh we got them in frankly short order
have we lost anyone because we didn't
have a bed
or we didn't have a ventilator or we
didn't have
health care staff no the president was
extending support for new swabs
so conversation commitment
uh promise made promise kept
my problem is i voted for now i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters trade
agreements like
nafta and permanent normal trade
relations with china which forced
american workers to compete against
people making pennies
an hour has resulted in the loss of 160
000 jobs the president is
absolutely right when he says that china
has been cheating for 25 years
and that bill clinton didn't do enough
about it george w bush didn't do enough
about it barack obama didn't do enough
about it
rising china is an incredibly positive
development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world rising china
is a positive
positive development it is in our
self-interest
that china continue to prosper we want
to see china rise
china is a great nation and we should
hope for the continued expansion
china is not our enemy we talk about
china
as our competitor we should be helping
the idea that china is going to eat our
lunch
is bizarre
they're not bad folks folks china's not
a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which you supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us oh do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the u.s mta is better
than nafta
it is better nafta now to be fair
maybe biden's not telling us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along
during a quickie escape the basement
trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that um
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh barrett
that was terrifying what kind of country
we're going to be
four more years of george georgia he uh
is going to find ourselves in a position
where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
[Music]
you know i like that because i say a lot
of words
you could never duplicate what you see
up there but you see the governors and
then they'll say
although some of them have been actually
very good but we've done a great job
and you see it there and that's what
their real feeling is but when they get
up to a mic well i don't know if he's
done that good
now we've done a great job if you want a
vaccine to kill the virus
a job to support your family and freedom
to
live your life to the fullest you have
to vote republican it's so important you
have to vote
so we're joined today with some really
great people and
a man that's right at the top of that
list for me is senator ron
johnson
i'm telling you you're lucky you have
him he's a fantastic man and he's done
an incredible job but he's got a lot of
courage too
and uh in washington he's respected by
everybody
also congressman glenn grothman
glenn
thank you glenn and mike gallagher mike
thanks man great job great guys
and somebody that's done a really good
job for us gop chairman
andrew hitt thank you thank you
how are we doing andrew uh cause we know
we're not gonna
fire you so damn you'll be out of here
andrew
no i think we're doing great yeah i
think we're doing great
i also want to thank a legendary
champion and a green bay packer
personified hall of famer brett favre
for his endorsement oh
you know i got he's a tough guy he's
great but
uh two days ago i saw that he endorsed
me and i just
want to thank him he's a hell of a
champion
he's a great champion i look at some of
his records you don't even realize it
but
when you look at passing yards and
touchdowns and
one thing about him tough as hell and
great and really talented so
i want to thank brett favre thank you
very much
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
now we are rebuilding if it's okay with
you
our nation
i ended the nafta nightmare and replaced
it with the brand new usmca
wisconsin dairy farmers were decimated
under the obama and biden plan
just think about it i only ran because
of them i said
that during the debate too i said joe
never thought of this
i ran because of you people because you
did such a bad job
he had no response to that with the
usmca
or dairy exports to canada are expected
to surge by more than
100 okay just went into effect
and we're not going to be losing our
companies to mexico and canada
we're not going to have our companies
close up and get rid of everybody fire
everybody
and move and do the same product in
mexico
you saw that for it's probably the
number one reason i ran i couldn't stand
watching it
and it's going to be now they're going
to pay a tremendous economic price if
they do that joe biden
is a corrupt politician
they took millions of dollars from the
chinese communist party
while vice president biden ship your
jobs to china
how the hell can he negotiate with china
with the money they take
and the news they don't want to cover it
the fake media the lame stream media and
the
and the companies right these wonderful
companies
that obviously don't love our country
it's suppression
they don't want to cover it if biden
wins china wins
his son walks in and takes out one and a
half billion dollars to manage billions
of dollars a year
they walk in where's hunter he wants to
know where's
where's hunter up from hill that's where
he is
where's my laptop hunter you left it at
a repair shop you never picked it up
and you know what they go russia did it
russia russia russia
ron it's russia i i know it's russia
i saw adam schiff you know watermelon
head like this
i believe that russia caused this
problem
russia ah yeah yeah here we go russia
russia russia
we have a great uh right head of dni he
said no it had nothing to do with russia
put out a very strong statement nothing
to do
if it does we let it know we let russia
know but they said that this is
pure disgusting evil stuff that goes on
and your tech companies don't want to
put it on
you you even even the new york post
which had real courage by the way
and they endorsed me two days ago i
would satellite but they had real
courage
and they took down the new york post
site can you believe it the new york
post the oldest newspaper in the country
fourth largest of the country they took
down the site
now we gotta get to the bottom of it and
we will with guys like kim
we will when we win wisconsin wins
when we win america wins and that's
what's happening under my leadership we
achieve
the most secure border in u.s history we
have now built
over 400 miles of wall
[Applause]
and will soon be finished they don't
talk about the wall anymore
they don't say they use that kill me i'd
go through it fight them and would close
up and would do all sorts of things and
they would go after me
once the wall started once they saw we
had all that money lined up to get it
done
and the impact it's had is incredible
it's not completed yet but it will be
very soon
and i built it exactly as border patrol
and ice wanted it
exactly i said what about concrete plank
they said sir that's no good have to see
through well
how about this and how about that all i
know it all that's what i like
they said sir we won steel we then won
concrete inside the steel and then we'd
like rebar
i said can you think of a more expensive
way maybe
but we gave it and then we won on top an
anti-climb you know the
thing on top i said why are we doing
that that's very expensive the piece of
steel on top
it's four feet deep they said sir that's
called anti-climb it's harder to climb i
mean i gave them
everything now they have no excuse i
don't want to have any excuses
and our record our numbers on the border
are phenomenal the best we've ever had
joe biden has pledged to open borders
mass amnesty
nationwide catch and release you know
what that is that's when you catch a
criminal
murderer rapist you let the criminal go
we argued about this during the debate
he said they all come back for trial no
they don't come back joe
only the ones i said with very low iqs
come back
you have a trial in two and a half years
for murder you have to come back
we released them and i ended it it's all
ended okay you think that was easy
it's not easy doing this stuff it looks
easy but it's not sanctuary cities from
coast to coast they want to have
sanctuary cities all over the place
and free health care for illegal aliens
which will bankrupt your medicare and
your social security
you will not have social security if you
do that or medicare we all have a big
heart i do i want to take care of
everybody
problem is you have millions of people
pouring in from all over the world if
you do this
as your president i will protect your
borders i will protect your families and
i will always protect
your medicare and your social security
and i've always said it biden and bernie
sanders
crazy bernie one of the greatest losers
of all time this guy
no but i meant that in a nice way
he lost and he went back to the senate
and voted radical left
then he lost again i mean elizabeth
pocahontas
warren all she had to do is get out a
couple of days early
he would have won every one of those
states but she decided not to do that
i don't think she likes bernie okay but
biden will increase refugees this was
agreed
with bernie and the group and aoc plus
three right
highly educated person on the
environment aoc
have you ever taken a class on the
environment i don't think so
increase refugees by 700
from terror hotspots now think of that a
700
this was agreed to i don't think bernie
was that bad i think actually bernie
went further left after they made the
deal
and i'm keeping radical islamic
terrorists the hell out of our country
okay if it's okay
look at what's gone on in france over
the last four days what what's happened
in france
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military
including nearly 6 billion to save the
historic shipyard
marinette marine
and even more money for combat vehicle
manufacturing in
oshkosh
you know marinette's doing a great job i
went to marinette four or five months
ago looked at what they were doing we
gave the contract to them
which cost me a lot of states but that's
okay
but we gave that to uh marinette they do
a great job
they do a great job they were ready to
close a six billion dollar contract and
it's going to be extended they make the
most
beautiful ship you have to see it looks
like a super yacht except it's got
weapons all over it did i say
i would say painted gleaming white and
call it a yacht but the weapons sort of
throw you off a little bit you
got more guns and things than that i've
never seen anything like it
anyway but they're fantastic biden will
close
the shipyard down he would close it down
he will cut your military spending
we need it and also it's all made in the
usa it's jobs it's great
best stuff and you know what two and a
half trillion dollars
with the envy of the world with the envy
of russia and china nobody has the
equipment that we have nobody
stealth fighter jets f-35s can't see
them
tanks we have tanks we have submarines
we have everything
what we've done and nuclear we've
upgraded our nuclear we have new nuclear
and all you do is one thing you pray
that we never have to use it
okay that's a big thing but having it
and having it in tippy-top condition
is the best way that we will never ever
have to use it
the best one the last administration's
cruel
va policies resulted in deadly
waitlists under biden and obama 300
000 veterans died on a waiting list
to fix this travesty we passed veterans
choice and va accountability
accountability for firing bad people
that don't love our vets and take care
of our vets
which you could not do under any
circumstances
civil service unions whatever and now
you can do it
jim you're not treating our vets right
get the hell out of here get fired okay
[Applause]
right and we took care of now our vets
instead of waiting for
weeks sometimes to see a doctor they go
to a private doctor we pay the bill
and it's actually honest it's less it's
probably less expensive
it's probably less expensive but much
more importantly
we take care of our vets you had vets
getting online by the time they saw the
doctor they became terminally ill
they actually had become terminally ill
waiting for so long so now they get out
immediately see a doctor and recently we
just got a 91
approval rating for the way we're
running the va
the vets from the vets
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
we took out the world's top terrorists
salamania is dead
number one terrorist in the world i
withdrew from the last administration's
disastrous iran
nuclear deal 150 billion dollars
for nothing you know what they gave 150
billion dollars john kerry that's he's
another genius
what a deal that was i recognized the
capital of israel and opened the
american embassy in jerusalem
presidents have been talking about doing
that forever
forever many many presidents they
campaigned on it and then they wouldn't
do it
and i understand why it was not easy to
do we had tremendous tremendous pressure
on us not to do it
but i did it i did it i just didn't take
anybody's phone call that's
all i also recognized israeli
sovereignty over the golan heights
they've been working on that for 52
years i got it done in two hours
and instead of never ending wars we are
forging peace all throughout the middle
east
for no money and no blood all over the
sand no blood
[Applause]
countries lined up want to make a deal
they all want to come in
after all these years and the other side
and everybody
they all said you could never do it this
way no you could never do it the way
they've wanted to do it for decades and
decades
i've done more in 47 months than joe
biden has done in 47 years
a vote for republicans is a vote for the
american dream
and remember the republican party is the
party of
the late great abraham lincoln right
gotta remember that
people forget that over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
which has already started
[Music]
[Applause]
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults and law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
said
dead thank god we will end the
big tech monopoly and restore freedom
of speech
we will defend the right to life
religious liberty
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength we will end
surprise medical billing require price
transparency already signed starts
january 1st will be
bigger than health care you watch lower
drug prices
even more and they'll be down 50 60
70 percent because i've invoked favored
nations
the drug companies big pharma they call
it does not like me too much
they have more ads and sleepy joe has
against me
every time you see one of those ads
remember you're drunk they're just
plummeting those prices are coming down
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions right
right america will land the first woman
on the moon in the united states will be
the first nation to land an
astronaut on mars
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education in our school
and we will teach our children to love
our country honor our history
and always respect our great american
flag
[Applause]
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
[Music]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america and standing up
for the great people of wisconsin i am
[Applause]
for some reason i like you you know why
i like you because we had a victory they
didn't think i was going to win
and we kept waiting for pennsylvania it
was obvious i was going to win but the
fake news didn't want to call
it because that would have meant the end
and then out of the blue
comes donald trump has won the state of
wisconsin
[Applause]
along with ron donald trump i was a very
pretty sound and that was it
that was it you know you were the one
you got us over the top you better do it
again
[Applause]
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
and get out to vote got to get out to
vote on november 3rd or previous to
november 3rd just get out the vote
whatever
whichever way you want to do it whatever
way you want to do it you got to get out
to vote this is a very serious
we're doing thank you thank you
thank you
thank you very much thank you i
appreciate it
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain the rest of the swamp we've
drained a lot of it
from madison to milwaukee from
janesville to kenosha
and from lacrosse to right here in green
bay i
love green
[Applause]
but i love kenosha too because we did a
great job there we showed them something
right we showed them how to stop them
that was sort of easy but i love kenosha
we inherit the legacy of wisconsin
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes
who crossed the oceans settled the
continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads raised up the great great
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america into the single
greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet
to come it is the best
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help you're do and we are
doing that have you noticed
a lot of things a lot of things are
changing very fast in dc
we need this final step this final step
it's going to be something but with your
devotion and your drive we are going to
keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of wisconsin
we have made america powerful again
our military is so powerful we have made
america wealthy again look at what's
happening to our country
[Music]
we have made america strong again we're
doing it with our
credible law enforcement and everyone
else
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you thank you
wisconsin
thank you with thank you green bay
get out and vote please get out and vote
most
important election of your lifetime
thank you everybody very much thank you
[Music]
you can stay there and i'm sure you will
find
many ways to have a
good time
it's fun to stay at the mca
it's fun
[Music]
you can have a good meal you can do
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
but you've got to know this thing
no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
it's funny
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
someone came up to me and said the man
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the
[Music]
is
[Music]
off the ground
[Music]
young man
[Music]
[Music]
shoes